un mes como presidente de perú y ya son
múltiples las crisis que afectan a pedro
castillo el sábado la fiscalía y la
policía registraron siete inmuebles de
su partido perú libre incluida la casa
del líder de la colectividad el marxista
vladimir cerrón por una supuesta
financiación ilegal a través de
presuntos sobornos pero para sus
seguidores es sólo una muestra de la
persecución
[Música]
ordinario puede ser una persecución
política
pero viendo veo nada
democrático como tiene y es que esto
ocurrió un día después de que el
congreso aprobara un voto de confianza a
favor del gabinete de castillos
criticado porque 6 de los 19 ministros
que eligió el presidente enfrentan
denuncias
a favor de la cuestión de confianza 73
congresistas en contra 50 abstenciones 0
en consecuencia ha sido aprobada la
cuestión de confianza el primer ministro
guido bellido es investigado por
apología del terrorismo tras manifestar
su apoyo al grupo sendero luminoso en
2015 y antes la primera crisis política
comenzó con héctor béjar el entonces
ministro de relaciones exteriores porque
en noviembre de 2020 este ex guerrillero
guevarista afirmó porque el terrorismo
en el perú lo inició la marina y esto se
puede demostrar históricamente y han
sido entrenados para eso por la cia
por eso los retirados de la fuerza
pública protestaron y el congreso le
abrió una moción que fue la que forzó su
renuncia tan sólo 19 días después de
asumir como ministro además ha habido
protestas a favor y en contra de
castillo quien según el último sondeo de
ipsos cuenta con una aprobación del 38
por ciento la más baja para un
presidente en los últimos 20 años